hey guys what's going on diavolo here
and in today's video we are going to be
going over nibaro kukasaki her
appearance
personality and all of the abilities
that we have seen so far in the jujutsu
kaizen universe but before we get into
all of that remember to hear about that
like button
and leave a comment down below with who
you'd like to see in the next character
analysis
if you're new around here be sure to
also subscribe if you're into anime and
especially jiu-jitsu guys and content as
it really helps out with the algorithm
but anyway let's get into it
the appearance of nobara kukusaki navara
is the tritagonist of jujutsu kaizen
she is a first year at the tokyo
metropolitan purse technical college
nobara is a short girl with orange eyes
and dark hair that is being dyed orange
to match her eyes
nabarro's school uniform consists of a
dark blue button-down
jacket a long skirt black stockings and
brown shoes
she also wears a light-colored belt to
hold her hammer
nails and straw doll while training
nobara wears a light-colored hoodie with
a dark flower pattern around her
shoulders black pants and white
shoes when in casual clothes nobara
wears a black sleeveless shirt
and a long black skirt the personality
of nobara kugasaki
nobaraku kasaki is a brash and extremely
confident woman with a strong belief in
being true to herself which has become
an unshakable characteristic for her as
we could see that even on the point of
her possible death she never begged to
be let go instead decided to
insult the cursed spirit she prides
herself on her physical appearance
taking great offense to anyone insulting
her and or attempting to hurt her face
she is the most outspoken of the trio
prone to taking charge when either
member of the team is unsure nobara took
some time to warm up to her new comrades
although she treasures their
companionship more after getting to know
them better
although compassionate and morally
uptight nobara is very stern
in her ideals believing only a few
important people in her life should sway
her feelings
she was also much less guilt-ridden over
the thought of having killed the death
paintings
she is also very talkative during battle
belittling and verbally
assaulting her opponents even while on
the verge of death
the abilities of nabarro kugasaki
nabarra is a
grade 3 sorcerer but she is showcased
above average skills when it comes to
being a juju sorcerer her abilities were
enough to be recognized by aoe toto and
have her recommended to be promoted to a
grade 1 sorcerer
she has also been shown to be physically
stronger than she looks
capable of kicking away an 80kg yuji
with not much visible effort
nabarro has shown incredible pain
tolerance when faced off against iso and
kichizu's curse technique
during that fight she not only withstood
the decomposition technique but she also
struck her arm with nails in order to
use them to attack her opponents with
resonance
with some of these nails also having
been inserted through her entire wrist
she has also shown an exceptional combat
skill when it comes to using your hammer
nails straw doll and rubber mallet when
it comes to equipment nobara is equipped
with a variety of different tools or
weapons they consist of a hammer which
nibara uses to either hammer the nails
into the straw door for her technique
hit the nails and fire them like
projectiles or simply hit the target
with
it straw doll is used by placing a piece
of her target within
or on the straw doll nobara hammers a
nail into the straw doll to cause the
target to
be destroyed nails nobara uses these for
multiple purposes
she can use them with her hammer
technique or fire them off like
projectiles
rubber mallet is a red and yellow hammer
used to attack humans so that she
doesn't kill them
nabarro has demonstrated to have a
strong grasp on jujutsu and the various
ways she can combat her opponents this
is the result of her innate technique
being very technical and requiring a lot
of thought nibara has shown her tactical
thinking during pretty much every battle
she has participated in
the tactical intelligence she has allows
nobara to gain the upper hand in
one-on-one battles
as we saw in episode 24 of jiu jitsu
kaizen through cursed energy
manipulation
ibarra successfully used a black flash
on kachizu
absolutely wasting him to the side black
flash is a technique that creates a
spatial distortion when a user connects
with an impact of cursed energy within a
span of 0.0001 seconds of a physical hit
the phenomenon causes the cursed energy
to flash back
creating an attack that is equal to a
normal hit to the power of 2.5
nabarro learned how to use black flash
during her fight against kichizu
bringing the curse to a near-death state
currently nobara has performed
at once straw doll technique nabarro's
innate technique allows her to use a
straw doll to attack the opponent from a
distance she can also use
charm weapons to perform her technique
she does this by
shooting the nails from a distance then
hitting them with her hammer
upon hitting a curse her curse energy
surrounds and enlarges around the now
exercising it resonance this technique
applies curse energy to the user's
target using a straw doll as an effigy
the user will generally use one body
part of their target to create the link
and then use resonance to apply damage
to more critical appendages of the
opponent's body
for example by placing a curse's severed
arm on the straw doll and striking it
with a nail
using a hammer the nails can be used to
pierce the target's cursed heart
the effectiveness varies depending on
the opponent's skill level the targeted
body part and the strength of the
connection to the user's target
if a link is made to multiple opponents
resonance will injure them all at the
same time
it also works on inanimate objects and
can disrupt someone else's control over
them
hairpin is a straw doll technique used
by nobara kugasaki
any nails that have been used as
projectiles can be detonated with an
explosion of cursed energy on command
using hairpin
nibara first used this technique to
destroy several trees surrounding momo
which sent momo flying closer to the
ground
and secondly on kachizu when she finally
killed him off
so that brings all of nobara kugasaki's
abilities
personality and appearance to an end if
you have enjoyed the video be sure to
hit the like button
and leave a comment down below with who
you'd like to see in my next character
analysis
also if you are new around here be sure
to hit that subscribe button especially
if you've enjoyed the content i make as
it really helps out with the algorithm
but for now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo and i'll see you guys
all in a bit
[Music]
bye